all right Heather Heather where you from
originally
where'd you grow up I was born in
Mission Hills and 700 balli California
and I go off till all right like sixth
grade and then I went to the high desert
valley and I moved back and forth from
there to Huntington Beach California
your whole life yep and tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
growing you know so my parents divorce
was sudden it was like good until then I
guess you know I didn't really know any
of the stresses or anything but they
ended up divorcing or separating when I
was seven and you know my mom she I
don't she had another boyfriend and I
don't know how long it was going on but
I knew when I was like I had to keep
that secret and then I saw my dad he
just moved Johnny's in Meech and I ended
up going with him versus my mother and
kind of was raised more or less bite by
him and my brother was there you know so
but you know at that age like I kind of
raised myself because my my father was a
drug user so but I I guess some of my
some of the the things that I know how
to do now are because I raised myself
basically so I guess it's like a sink or
swim situation sounds shitty but in your
adulthood I guess it paid off if you
will and how was your childhood any
crazy I mean yeah I started using drugs
and drink when I was 12 because I didn't
know I didn't have anybody else to talk
to I didn't have anybody at all the
people that I did pick to be you know I
thought were my you know we're always
older and obviously handing me you try
this on try that yeah okay and you know
pretty soon I started using you know
you know that's what my go-to was I
don't I don't know even to this day I
don't know any other way than to just go
and you know go back to what the drugs
were using it that yeah well I start
with marijuana obviously and then uh
drinking and and then one day the person
that I thought was gonna sell me
marijuana
so let me Chris woman that was Amana was
a whole another you know life
different people different whole of your
life
yeah I didn't really have a childhood
really I just kind of raised myself I
don't I don't remember even um I
remember just keep getting back passed
back and forth from my parent from my
mom to my dad like if one got tired of
me then okay you take her now oh you
know I was always kind of envious of my
brother because he got both of my
parents and until and he wouldn't you
know he was 18 so he's more well-rounded
than I know he's got everything's very
put together he's a he's a very
successful person and so was my father
but you know I I guess he's a weekend
warrior and and it just to this day I
you know things resurfaced and it just
kills me some of the situations that I
deal with as a child so I wasn't like
molested or raped or anything like that
just emotional stress and how don't
worry if you know that like oh uh we
don't have food and I was beat my dad
made it plenty of money but he would go
spend it so those stresses aren't meant
for children you know like the bills are
or getting yourself up for school and
like not having anybody you know that's
what a dream when you left home
I was 17 I moved to the valley and I
became a stripper oh really
shut up back back the henna wasn't like
you know they're gonna cart like of
course they asked for ID and you just
give them you know you go get one on
alvaro no penis you know you just give
that to them but yeah I was I wanted to
grow up so fast because I felt like that
was the only way I was gonna have be
able to live the life that I wanted to
live you know I mean I know my dad tried
but I guess having those stresses he
just he's a good father of it
I think he you just he went crazy just
it doesn't much as you know anybody what
I guys after you know that and working
as a stripper as a young girl the drugs
get go ahead yeah yeah and uh I just
started using cocaine and I think those
ecstasy was the big thing at the time
with xanax and you know that was and
then crystal meth obviously to you know
keep the weight off and you know and to
be able to just go go go go go I and
then drinking a lot drink a lot I got my
first DUI when I was 19 and that's when
like I I had you know I drove my driver
side window so but the life of a you
know when you first moved down here we
just had we had just so much money we
didn't know what to do with we just go
you know vacations all this iron just
every single day with our like drug
dealers you know Vegas one week and then
all right dislike because we feel like
it and it's crazy it was crazy money you
know it was it was a fun time I wouldn't
take it back but I went through I I saw
things I was very shocked I felt like I
guess I was sheltered I didn't really
know how to do much and you know I was
just very simplistic like you know I
don't know it was different than a
different life different life I felt
like I led a whole life and then when I
came back to
I'm end up moving I stop stripping one
day and just some guy did did something
really disgusting he just grabbed me I
like sat me on his lap and he just like
finished and in his pants and and like
he wouldn't let me up and I just said
you know that that was the last time
because it really wasn't who I was in my
you know in my heart but I just so I
just quit and I moved back to Palmdale
to try to regroup and just maybe be act
my age made me have my maybe just be
able to be who I wanted you know who I
was I was meant to be and I just felt
like when I met kit you know other
people my age which was 19 I just I I
feel like I lived a whole life you know
is that 15 and 16 I was in Hollywood on
Sunset Boulevard with a fake ID drinking
with you know a lot of famous people and
just like oh I don't have to too much
you know I just I learned early as long
as you look cute and smile and maybe not
here you know you just you're in like
you know everything will be handed to
you really so I mean I was crazy as
insane after stripping with very let's
go
I like I said I just I moved to Palmdale
back to mama no because I after that I
just I had a falling out my roommate she
was it just
she was always intoxicating really
thought that she even had a drug
font-weight:bold you know you're not
gonna admit that hey I think we're we
got a problem here no it's just every
day you wake up you get high and get
drunk or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do get late whatever it everything
anything goes and and there's a lot of
backstabbing a lot of conniving and just
debauchery and she she and I just didn't
couldn't couldn't meet I - I like I at
at some point like I was I really I did
have like other words a little morals
and values and respect and I just I just
couldn't keep throw up you know for lack
of a better word [ __ ] myself off I
wanted I wanted something different you
know
to be back around my family or whatever
and so I moved back and within I think
it was like a couple months I ended up
meeting my ex-boyfriend and at the pizza
I had a vintage Boston Pizza that's when
like I started using like meth like full
time like every day all day that was
like the the thing that they did in
Bombay a hole and one night I just got
really drunk and my daddy's the reason
why is because my home I wasn't wasn't
great like everybody looks at you like
you know as long as you look put
together they don't really ask you know
how you're doing like they just think oh
you know she's always at it like that
she's got it good you know blah blah
blah really I'm like this broken little
you know skeleton snot it was you know
Cryptkeeper inside and just wanting you
know to be to be you know searching for
love and all that acceptance whatever so
again my dad you know he stopped using
drugs for the little while and and then
again he picks it back up and there's
again these prostitutes in my house all
the time and and you know and he's all
and he don't come home and and and when
he does come home he's got like this
gnarly story and he's got like like blah
I just like one one day he got shot in
the arm for love of God like I mean it's
the whole car it was like blood I just
as scheduled daylights out of me but I
just I didn't want to be home and when I
come home I'd have to kick these
prostitutes and people out and clean up
you know pretend like it just didn't
even happen you know because that's what
we did we just we never talked about we
just you know we were on the road I
guess if you will and just pretend like
I didn't see that I didn't hear that you
know
I mean I guess my dad went through a lot
but I just didn't want it I didn't I
didn't like being home you know but I
was there because he asked me to help
him like you needed me because for
whatever reason I and I believed him
so and then when he'd meet somebody
eventually then then I wouldn't be
needed anymore and I'd you know he'd
move out and I just be left like okay I
guess I'll you know go figure something
out for myself you know so you have a
family of your own
I do I do but I my daughter's father he
uses when I first moved in decanting got
any heat I met him at his house my
friend bought me because he was having a
barbecue and like we just instantly like
connected and I think we had we had
gotten pregnant like a month I find man
it was the best you know is the best
thing but I had been too you know I've
been in and out of jail I got like four
duis and during that you know from 19 to
27 and Jade a bunch of jail time and
everything you shouldn't do I probably I
did I just I know a chill button so when
I met hand I was I was third I was 29
and like I said I just had gotten out of
jail maybe a couple of months prior to
that and we just clicked I guess and you
know I'm venosum II got pregnant and
within a month and we just decided you
know why he was already old
he's about I think about 15 years older
than me and I was just like well we know
we're adults why don't we just you know
do have the baby so we did and she's you
know she's the love my heart you're the
light of my life but um we we I hung in
there for six years you know we had a
house in Canyon Country pool jacuzzi
you know gardener everything you know my
daughter very very very very lucky she
was able I mean I gave her anything she
wants
I was with her everyday is nowhere else
I I wanted to be
I was domesticated I was a paralegal I
do accounting a bookkeeping like you
know I I paid the bills you know I took
care of her and you know you just you
didn't do anything like there most of
our pictures are of just me and her
because he never got out of bed because
he was always on drugs I didn't notice
that I didn't know what he was on until
like two years later because I was never
using something on his antics or didn't
you know vicodin it was uh I just can't
understand why you'd always have mood
swings and why he'd always be wanting to
lay down on time so um and he would just
verbally you know attack me things
worked you know it's perfect and I mean
I know I mean perfectly this coffee cup
better it'd be in the same position as I
put it the day before the important
before and the way he would do it if you
were in the kitchen then if he'd walk in
you'd have to walk out cuz otherwise
he'd yell at you why are you in the
kitchen when I you know just you know I
cooked him dinner every night after an
eight-hour day come home take my you
know take care of my baby I wanted to
show my parents that I could I could be
responsible at all I could have you know
this life that you know but but when the
doors closed they had no idea like what
I really went through so and I just for
my daughter's sake I never wanted her to
see any you know ugly or like build you
know feel like I do you know have two
parents you know what different homes
just don't where I don't want her to go
through that so I just stuck it out you
know so
and pretty soon you know you can't beat
them join them
so I well I had my boot my breast
augmentation I gear after she was born
and they gave me vicodin and that that
was probably the beginning of the the
end I I you know I just I drank still
and didn't see a problem with it usually
we should go to my mom's house you know
every other weekend or whatever so me
and her daughter dad would just you know
party like if we were freaking 16 years
old is suing the most and you know by
Sunday clean up our act and make sure
you don't pick out the baby I like it
nothing happened you know but it was
just a crate he was very different just
into the drug scene and knew a lot of
bad shady people and you know I just was
I was a I just like I said you can't
beat him joining when I started this job
in North Hollywood and it was it was one
of the best jobs I did have and it paid
the most but it was just very stressful
and it couldn't handle it so I just
started using a bike in a 1-1 and then
next thing you know I'm asking for two
and the next thing you know I'm asking
for xanax and and the next thing you
know I'm not doing my job
but and then I ended up in I ended up
taking my car out one night and crashed
it and I and it was parked in my front
yard and I didn't even know how the hell
it got there and I thought I had was
over those days like oh I'm not doing
the driving ever you know and I said
holy [ __ ] and I said you know why I got
a I gotta do something about this and I
just because like I said in my family
you don't talk about what's really going
on you just you know unless you get
caught or like oh god oh [ __ ] but I just
called my mom's like I need to go to
rehab and I've been to Rio when I was 15
because of crystal meth but
and because I got kicked out of high
school so I just I have this just way
about it I just like to do what I want
when I want and I don't care what I'm
when I was supposed to do this is what
I'm doing but when I was when I became a
mother like I just I I did everything
the right way and it still ended up it's
such an ugly path you know I'm still I'm
still struggling without every every
second you know just I hate being away
from her and that's the reason why you
know I can get my [ __ ] together because
it was like there's um there's no
happiness you know there's no it's not
living you know without her I just I I
was accused I was drunk
I thought I was drinking and her dad I
accuse me of like driving drunk with her
like dragging out and he made a report
basically and the cops came and it was
like ugliest thing I ended up getting
arrested I that as I'm getting arrested
they it's like they the CPS I was
already informed met me at the station
and told me well since you're her only
guardian guess like your you know your
your daughter's not gonna be with you
anymore you know you just go to your
parents like you lost custody like
you're losing custody right now so but
six hours later I was let out and
everything was you know straightened out
and I was you know they were able to see
that I didn't do any other thing but
because see if he has already got
involved I'm writing this this wave and
so I'm doing everything that they wanted
me to do I'm thinking in two months or
whenever the court date was I think
maybe two or three months down the road
she's gonna come back home
and every night I'm telling her you know
at this point they made they also made
me move out of my mom's house because I
moved us to there because I couldn't be
with him anymore
they made me move out of my mom's house
because I couldn't be I couldn't spend
the night at her husband because if
Ashley was there and trying to tell your
daughter everything that's all she's
fibers wool she's even with me trying to
tell her rug you know sorry like I can't
I gotta go let me just leave watching
her crack my mom crying is it time I
wear my shirt up you know and uh in the
court three months later I just you know
do it the closet they want me to do and
I of course see it wasn't good enough so
there was later I'm expected here to be
able to come on I'm telling my baby okay
just another couple week you know and
they say well no she's not gonna come
home with you you know she
you didn't do thinner you got to do this
isn't that so
I lost it I just lost it it's painful
you know it's painful and I mean people
they don't understand me I I just I law
I just couldn't keep my [ __ ] together
and so one item you know get him I'm
drinking cuz I don't know what the [ __ ]
else to do with myself and my friends
doing you know goes and get some heroin
and I'm like okay cool you're getting
here away
it also and I'm like well well I want to
try on see how I miss a few guys I said
well [ __ ]
he's pretty know maybe I'd like to try
that okay well you need to smoke no no I
want to do it like you like I'm doing it
like you so he tries to give me this
speech I'm like yeah yeah save it you
know who cares I'm not gonna end up like
you know I don't know like that it's not
gonna happen to me and it Jesus Christ I
think I was using like two grams of
heroin a day driving from Palmdale I
don't even think I think I took a shower
changed my clothes or brush my hair for
like three at the first like three weeks
for sure I think I was just a a sleigh
like you get up you go to sleep ass out
cuz you're high you get up and you just
go to the dealer right away and I mean I
had the I had really nice bags I had you
know money save I had a car I had
everything and by the time that was all
over I this is where I've ended up like
you know I cleaned up my act a few times
but I just keep getting involved with
these people that just are abusive and
cruel and they take everything you know
they they build you up you know in the
beginning and you just believe them
you're like okay you know and then all
of a sudden you know they're calling
they're they're you know they put their
hands on you beating you and and you
know these awful names call these awful
names cheating on you like just
Tinky you know what's left of you
showing your what's left of me basically
and just [ __ ] trashing it so I just I
just wanted to die like I just been I'm
like you know I just got into that my
mine friend like who cares if I'm gonna
be gone like I'm you know maybe my
daughter would be better off like and
you know I thought that my daughter
better off if I don't know if I don't
call because I don't want to upset her
make her think about me you know
so I'm alright yeah gross strange for a
couple months it is not right you know
but
my mom didn't want me to come sear in
the nut cups it was just just it's like
a such [ __ ] really it's your guilt
keeps you sick and it keeps you away for
the people that you love the most
because you don't know what to say you
don't have an excuse a there's no excuse
in the world why you're not there with
your baby
hey why you're not working on yourself
to get it back there but when you're on
the street and you're walking around at
3:00 a.m. and you know nobody's thinking
about you you're just on your own it's a
pretty [ __ ] up lonely feeling and you
know for me I can't just write it out I
gotta you know I need something to make
me feel better because that's all that I
that's all that I know every person I
relied on left or lied or dated me some
way or another you know even my parents
at some point it's like if I can't trust
them who can I trust you know nobody
really and and everyone you know
pretends that they're your friend and
they're nice they're gonna do this that
and the other but really they just want
you know they want what they want and
I've had to put my self aside and uh for
like basic human necessities which
somebody shouldn't have to do for you
know just to take a shower whatever he
ate you know just stupid little things
that people take advantage of or I don't
know just if I had I could have gone
somewhere I just because of this
situation it I'll never be the same like
I'll never I could never go back to the
person I was I was there is such a
difference in pictures from before when
I was my baby until now I'm just like
this I don't even look the same and I've
just seen so many things that I somebody
just doesn't ever want to see it I know
I mean it is ugly you just you don't
know how ugly the world is until you
have nothing
and you're and you have too much prior
to ask for stuff but but if you find
yourself now prostituting yourself
because nobody else is gonna give you
money and you know
you don't want to work because you want
to do drugs all day because the but you
don't want to really do drugs you're
just trying to be a normal again it's a
sick [ __ ] cycle but it'll end up you
know it'll end you up on the wrong side
of the tracks and unfortunately I was
living in Laughlin and I was in the same
[ __ ] there as I'm doing here and I just
I try to I one day I wake up I want to
save the world the next day I'm just
like [ __ ] it out I'm Carol I'm just
gonna OD and you know end it all and a
couple weeks ago somebody did give me
fentanyl and I did die and you know you
don't realize like once that happens it
makes you it makes you take life a
little more serious like maybe I don't
want to die maybe I do you want to do
the right thing you know
I just got an argument Jonathan and
which was my a my ex-boyfriend now um I
just got her arguing with him and it
would've been the last time you talked
to me just last time anybody would see
me you know but my family doesn't reach
out to me like they turned their back
right now and I guess they think that I
should go to rehab or whatever but you
know it's like I don't know why they why
they're just so judgmental they don't
understand like I like literally had a
mental breakdown and nobody's asking me
I'm okay you know if I'm okay lately
just carry on like oh well like you know
it just sucks so just keeps me you know
in the streets more I mean I'm not
trying to feel sorry for myself but I
guess that's really what's happening I
can't seem to do this sober and I don't
know when you know something's gonna
change I mean yeah I could I could go
and I could pretend to like somebody and
you know because that's all these men
want is you know probably a pretty girl
and you know for basically you to smile
a nod and I could have you know I can
have a house and I can have the guard I
can have everything but I don't I'm just
I'm sick of I'm sick of doing that I'm
just gonna pretend I don't I want to be
happy and that's so happiness for me you
know but I don't know I just I have
poles but I know at some point you just
you know nothing ever goes right you
know I'm a great great starter but you
know just can't seem to finish anything
and so say boyfriend cheating on me and
like three days ago he kicks me out of
my house and pretty as well he's
sleeping with an the girls downstairs we
had roommates and and and looks me in
the eye and tells me I would never do
that
Lola and we got in an argument and he
just he just didn't want to be with me
anymore so he had the the manager kicked
me out because that's the girl that he's
screwing cousin so of course he's gonna
have loyalty to her and kicks me out and
you know and so I end up back here you
know cuz I came here two months ago then
we got a place and then you know and
then I'm here again and I mean these
people some of them they're the most
generous beautiful souls I've ever met
like give me more than my family like
feed me and show me love don't judge me
you know just took me in and helped me
but then there's ones that you know they
make you think they're gonna do that and
then all of a sudden you're you're in
somebody's apartment with eight dudes
and you're just like holy [ __ ] out and I
get here because you just got you don't
know you know they already have a plan
for you before you're even five you know
five feet away so you know it's a it's a
learning lesson for sure and you can't
trust everybody that you want to and
there's a lot of wolfs and she hears
clothing as they say but uh you know
there's things that go on here that I
would never even think possible that I
never thought I would witness like there
was
was bad bad things you know and uh
what's what's the worst thing you've
seen murder somebody caught murdered and
he was screaming for help and I can
there's nothing that you can do because
you don't want to put herself that visit
you know like you don't want to okay
kill yourself just for like China and
what could you what could I have done
really no he's another two men like you
know he was uh he was taken from his
tent I was next door waiting for my
friend to come back and all I could hear
was was you know his blood-curdling
seems like I don't know please know and
and help me in the distance and and and
I was then you know it stops and you
just wait there's no and I didn't have a
phone on me at a call and I'm just going
this is not really this is not really
happening this is this is fake and then
so I you know the next guy I'm like
shaking like a leaf and I just I'm like
I can't believe that there's that this
goes on but I mean they say they talk
about like I see I just happened but you
really don't think is ever gonna happen
around you or in front of you like this
is just for the movies or whatever drop
dramatic you know but no it happened and
and then I see his picture on the on the
door of like these places on my holy
[ __ ] like like I don't know who did that
this you know to him but I know that
he's never coming back I asked one of
the you know the neighbors the by the
tent where I was at and I said you know
like you see do you think this is what
happened oh yeah that is yeah you never
came back and I think you don't know
what somebody did did it you know nobody
deserves it but you don't know what was
I did to get to that point I mean holy
it really scares you and to just wanting
to run away but where do I run away I
don't know home you know you want to go
home but where it where is that so
you're on Skid Row now where you live
give her ten I know I have friends that
I stay with like you know one day I'll
see what is right and it
you know just then just find a place
yeah I mean everybody you know when
you're pretty I guess when they think
I'm pretty and you know you just my good
looks get me somewhere or sexual favors
part of your no well not with my friends
no even though I'm sure it's like an
undertone it's mostly probably expected
but but I try not to to think about it
you know sometimes you just got to do it
you have to do what you do to support
your drug habit
I don't usually pay for jobs but if I
have to I do I prosecute when I've been
I've been prostituting myself for a
month now I guess it's it's it's not who
I am I just kind of separate myself from
that you know from that person and I
just started pretend like you didn't
happen like I got money man like I can
just you know I'm sure it'll catch up
with me someday but right now you know
I'm just trying to get through the day
like I've I never stole anything in my
life and all of a sudden I'm nob and
he's still things because otherwise you
know I'm not gonna have it and I need it
you know like I said it's just it's a
it's a shitty it's a shitty life you
know and I just I need to I just start
you know doing the right thing and
everyone who you need to go to rehab and
I just I feel like I'm not ready yet you
know I just unfortunately I'm not
he's your daughter with her father yeah
she's with her dad and with my parents
and it just seems like every time I try
my hardest just there's something that
to stop it it's like well what the [ __ ]
am I supposed to do like I've done
everything I you know I I just don't
know I don't I just what do you think
the core
addiction is something that happened
early in childhood I just think it's a
abandonment issues and it's and it's not
feeling like I was important enough to
you know never being good enough always
pushed to the side like uh you know like
what I have to say is not important to
anybody and nobody gives a [ __ ]
I've hunt your feelings you know always
having to rely on myself because I never
had anybody to talk to you like I'd see
these families that I'm just so envious
you know and I just I tell you no little
girl like her you know whatever kid just
just be your age you know just live your
you know live your childhood like don't
be so quick to grow up like you know cuz
you definitely could just it goes so
fast and I just wish that you know I was
from for my daughter's sake I you know I
did cute things of the her to keep her
you know I just hope that her dad and my
parents you know they they do say you
don't have a name 7:06 she was she's
gonna be seven every breaks my I wasn't
able to be there for her birthday or or
Christmas and I just what I mean there's
nothing I could say that whatever you
know what do you think people know
things that are not addicts don't
understand about addiction it's because
we're it's emotional damage it's it's
PTSD really it's it's just as bad maybe
if you've gone to war people put up with
things and see things that they just it
it's [ __ ] shocks you and it and and
it's so upsetting to you to your soul
that you know you block it out you block
it out boy and then I should get older
things start reserving seeing a maybe a
song will play or you'll smell something
you know just all of a sudden you're
inch you know up [ __ ] creek you know
battle and I think that a lot of people
they're trying to self-medicate as well
for my depression I use heroin for
weight loss I use meant
that's about it you know when you're
addicted to heroin you're just trying to
get enough so you could feel normal
yeah yes same cousin is very different
right because it's anxiety I think a lot
of people if they they were given the
right medication and they took it the
right way and they were I think they'd
be a hole in a whole different world
because there are very good people out
here but they're also you know the
animals and the the bad you know the bad
guy bad but for the most part I just
think that you know people just
judgmental it's okay to oh well you're a
drugget well I wonder why I like you
know it's emotional pain I think and
it's anxiety it's just self medication
self medicating I don't think that they
they wanted to grow up and say and you
know be talking to themselves you know
on the corner in their tent like I don't
think that they wanted that first
filming you know [ __ ] went down and they
got [ __ ] their brain you know hurt like
you know did a 180 I as I'm you know as
I'm here I understand that and I can I
can relate and I don't judge and I
accept everybody but before and unless
you're in that situation unless you've
gone through it you're gonna you know
you're very quick to judge that oh what
a [ __ ] loser like I'll never be like
that well hopefully you're not like that
but if you do end up like that you know
you just may be a I don't know I think I
think it's sad because they're the first
like I said that the first people that
will give you their shirt off their back
versus someone in you know that a family
member even a friend I just think they
know what it's like you know they've
you know you you never know what it's
gonna be like your first day on the
street like you're just supposed to
figure this out like you're you know
people are so scared to death but I
think that once you're able to survive
and I think there's a lot of finessing a
lot of manipulation a lot of bartering I
think that you could survive anywhere
and I think it's uh it made me you know
stronger and I'm able to find Who I am
maybe I needed that a little bit because
uh you know when it going from like
having stuff to not having it and being
able to still be happy and survive and
laugh through it you know says something
you know I don't know what that is but
there's a lesson learned and I'm
grateful I'm grateful to to be able to
like I can be an you know a chameleon
really like be with people that I have
money people that don't have money I can
fit in with everybody because I've been
in each stage I feel like so um I guess
that's a you know one up I guess that do
you think there's a chance that you
might not get out of here
no I don't know she and I never thought
about that well I don't know I some day
that I just want to shoot myself in the
face honestly I just I sometimes I walk
around and I just you know and these
people it's like the second coming of
Jesus I think I'm like the only white
girl here
I don't know well the other ones are a
little crazy but um sometimes I just I'm
like where am I going what should I do
with myself why am I not going back to
my career or or my trying to work
towards my family or why you know why
this why that
and then I'll sudden I find myself hi
again and well you know I'll go tomorrow
I'll do this tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow well I don't know and like I
said a couple weeks ago I'm I didn't
know if tomorrow would have came IOD and
uh and died and luckily the people that
were around me cared about me and they
gave me Nora can and it took two of them
and then they and they did call 9-1-1
and even though they had gods in this
and
the other they didn't they put
themselves aside to save my life enough
for that I'll always be grateful so you
just never know
you just never know I think it's
important to just live your life you
know and just be as happy as you can and
and do the right thing and by people and
you know and I love more than give love
more than hey you know at least try not
to that you know be an [ __ ] you're
like you know I think that I'm a giver I
just I love to see if you can make you
can be kind to somebody you know it
could make their day or their life you
know you've even taken a couple minutes
out of your time to make them smile and
laugh because they're always on edge you
know wondering if someone's gonna get
over on them you know is is something
that you know is invaluable I think and
they'll remember you by that you know so
I think you should be remembered by you
know something good words this soup
versus being an [ __ ] beautiful all
right Heather thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah thank you good luck thank you are
getting back together with your daughter
yes thank you Thanks
you